en direct avec nos de glace y est
professeur de droit spécialiste de la
science politique américaine bonjour
merci d'être avec nous qu'elle est en
filigrane l'intention des etats-unis
ok 1 à 3 couches au aux surfaces y aune
en visite qu'ils consomment le
pandémique
mais pourquoi une visite on présente
hier maintenant je voudrais bien être
avec vous sur le plafond mais on peut
faire une autre communication par vidéo
conférence donc en a le soupçon que le
visitent n'ai pas vraiment peur se
renseigner de la réussite est très loin
donc derrière ça le deuxième couche
allant la politique étrangère un
nouvelle guerre froide qui se monte
entre les etats-unis et la chine et la
visite d'un ministère est un coup contre
la chine c'est l'intention de
l'administration prend après une
plusieurs choses comme type toc ou à et
les sanctions fermeture de consulats
maintenant il envoie le ministre à
taiwan mais le troisième couches plus
profondes
c'est le pronostic domestique trempe il
baisse dans les sondages il veut gagner
l'élection et donner des coups durs à la
chine sans lui c'est un homme politique
domestique
il a expliqué nous le fanboy justement
de cette visite à taïwan qu'est-ce que
cela signifie
vis-à-vis de la chine c'est un livre
rouge pour la chine la chine a déclaré
son intention de signifier taïwan l'île
avec le compte des notes
même avec la force et la chine a envoyé
deux avions de chasse après se visite et
donc les transitions sont assez haut et
pour tenter de menacer la chine avec une
ligne 2 comme ça menace tout le monde
entier leur guerre entre la chine et les
états unis
est impensable quelles sont les
relations aujourd'hui jusque là des
états unis avec taïwan
c'était toujours des bonnes relations
on a toujours gardé même après la
rupture des relations diplomatiques
les rapports commerciales avec les
thannois
et aussi on est les plus grandes
donneurs d ordre ottawa mais avec
l'administration 30 qui a
instrumentalisé le pronostic très
mauvaise pour se battre contre la chine
on avait un rapprochement et c'est ces
malheureuses que cinq retient açores au
mal prononcé le nombre de premier
ministre pendant cette visite c'est un
mât la pro a pour l'administration
mais si on regarde bien taiwan peuvent
être un collège pour les états unis pour
provoquer la chine parce que la chine
n'a pas toujours la capacité navale pour
bien prendre les îlots les états unis
dominent toujours les eaux de mer et
pour l'instant je ne peux pas imaginer
une raison lorsque les états unis
continuent à se défendre alors on a bien
compris le poids de cette image de cette
rencontre entre un représentant des
états unis et la présidence taiwanaise
mais au delà du symbole surtout est ce
que ça peut déboucher très concrètement
est ce que l'on peut imaginer par
exemple que les etats unis reconnaissent
taïwan comme un état indépendant
non depuis 79 danse la bière fois contre
le soviet 1e contre la russie les
etats-unis ont décidé dans la balance of
our de soutenir la montée en puissance
de la chine pour contrer
pouvoir de l'art aussi et ça continue à
être le jeu des états unis donc nos les
états unis ne va pas aurait connu taïwan
comme un diktat à part mais il va
utiliser très bon dans une région comme
ils utilisent et israël dans le est de
la méditerranée comme une guerre contre
ses ennemis est une provocation pour les
grandes puissances montant qui est la
chine
quelles peuvent être les répercussions
de cette visite sur la chine et sur les
relations qu'elle entretient avec les
états unis
ouais d'abord la chine a signalé qu'il
n'aime plus présidente trempe qui la
chine président angie par exemple
considère comme président 30 et trop
provocatrice n'est pas fiable n'est pas
stable donc peut-être la chine va faire
une ingérence dans les élections
présidentielles américains pour soutenir
la candidature de présider l'epad du
mois ça c'est ce qu'on dit dans le les
légendes urbaines
merci beaucoup d'âmes a pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions douglas y est
professeur de droit spécialiste de la
science politique américaine